Salut, c’est Juliette !
En ce moment, on parle beaucoup de l’Angleterre,
mais toute l’attention portée
à la famille royale
et l’argent dépensé pour
les obsèques de la reine
ne plaisent pas
à tout le monde.
Je voulais savoir comment les jeunes vivent cette période.
Du coup, je suis partie
en Angleterre,
dans le nord-ouest,
à Liverpool.
C’est une ville portuaire
qui est connue
pour son club de foot,
Liverpool,
et aussi des Beatles,
mais c’est aussi
une ville connue
pour son taux de pauvreté
et sa violence.
Là-bas, j’ai rencontré un jeune qui s’appelle Marcus.
Il a 21 ans et il a grandi
toute sa vie à Liverpool.
Lui et ses amis trouvent qu’on parle trop de la monarchie
et que ça coûte
trop cher au pays.
Marcus, il vit encore
chez ses parents
et il cumule deux jobs
pour pouvoir s’en sortir.
Il est réceptionniste
dans un salon de tatouage
et aussi caissier
dans un supermarché.
Le coût de l’enterrement
de la reine
est estimé à
35 millions d’euros
et ce n’est que le début
des dépenses.
Le couronnement de Charles,
la fabrication
de nouveaux passeports
et des nouvelles pièces
avec la tête du nouveau roi
vont aussi coûter
beaucoup d'argent.
À cette époque, énormément d’usines ont dû fermer
partout à Liverpool et
dans le nord de l'Angleterre.
Résultat : le chômage et
la pauvreté ont explosé.
Et depuis, les choses n’ont pas beaucoup évolué
et la ville se sent abandonnée encore aujourd’hui
par le gouvernement.
Le Royaume-Uni,
c’est un des pays
où les inégalités de revenus sont les plus fortes au monde.
Plus d'un cinquième
de la population
vit en situation de pauvreté.
Ça représente
14,5 millions de personnes
et la majorité d’entre elles
vit dans le nord du pays.
Après un gros accident
et un long arrêt
maladie cette année,
Marcus veut absolument retourner travailler,
mais son rêve,
c’est de reprendre
ses études
dans le domaine
de la psychiatrie.
Merci d’avoir regardé
cette vidéo,
j’espère qu’elle
vous a intéressé.
Si jamais vous avez une idée
d’un autre sujet
que vous voulez que j’aborde,
n’hésitez pas à m’envoyer
un message sur Instagram.
À la prochaine !